how's it going bros my name is pan fire
we're playing catherine this game is so
much fun
let's just keep playing oh it's getting
late
oh we're having a nightmare this is the
second day alright this is not good
[ __ ] sheeps and [ __ ]
oh so you can see that man I can't move
let's have to click stage 2 prison of
despair
alright cool it looks a lot worse pass
out it's like our girlfriend said and we
kind of like go in and out alright this
looks ok yeah
they'll break out
so whenever you see a new blog receipt
okay where what kind of monster
crackling yeah I see them let's try it
out so you get a combo meter up there
yay pillow whoa laughs way there all
right how do I do it nothing to stand on
when you pull a block if you try to move
to a space without a block you'll hang
as well from there you can move around
it's a useful way to maneuver okay got
it
look at that [ __ ] MLG Pro all right I
got it if you can't see ahead of you try
looking around Oh what do we got then
I'm not stuck
we can't go over there dad damn it my
combo I hear the clock we're almost at
the top
fantastic it's [ __ ] frictions ooh so
they could fall now I fight [ __ ] out
we got a prize then a checkpoint we'll
start from there if you need to retry if
you come across one be sure to tag I
mean I'm pretty sure I know what a
[ __ ] checkpoint it'll get this point
in my life I've been through a lot
should I be doing this with an edge
I feel like you're gonna easily [ __ ] up
in a game like this okay I'll push these
yeah who's everyone this game is so
mysterious that an inch
edge all right all right we did it
Brothers hat back grab it you must eat
ah-yi
safety bonus I'll take it thank you very
much I might be playing uneasy but it
did say you shouldn't play normal if you
haven't played before so um okay cool
great it's loading how are you doing
it's cute how do you think I care oh my
god no I'm just kidding tell me more I
should start
so seriously this place wish I knew
one thing's for certain though if we
don't run
this is so [ __ ] weird we all have the
same favor if you don't want to die
you've got a climb
take a look see that Bell it's like a
church or something
we can reach the top there may be a way
to escape so there is a way like I said
there's no guarantee so everyone see
themself not as a sheep
I'm afraid you're on your own I like
it's a haircut now Kauai is [ __ ] you
hurry - and his ass I wish I was a shoes
that'd be [ __ ] sweet you can save
your progress and talk to the other
sheet go on talk to them okay all right
all right and well you know what I will
talk to the sheet fantastic great talk
what is this I save here I do save you
all right all right all right all right
all right let's talk to you how you
doing mr. sheet
why are you Joel just singer then
people trying to trick me
oh my god but you're so fluffy and cute
come on what about you oh my god you're
the ones standing by a [ __ ] ledge
with your back to me all right
don't threaten to kick me off [ __ ]
hell
all right what about you shut up or calm
down
I guess this is like good or bad choice
shut up snap out of it yeah I was right
okay so maybe that's what another thing
that affects the story is like if you
choose to help other people or not I
kind of want to do an evil playthrough
because I think that's probably what
most people don't do all right let's sit
in the elevator okay thank you is
marriage the point where life begins or
ends pull the rope with the answer that
best matches your truth oh man I don't
know I wouldn't say either
I'm gonna go with the ends what am i you
breath are you doing all this I merely
watch over the sheep someone else
dropped you here in the real world
wanted you to be dropped someone in the
real world
oh if you want the truth since you seek
survival I will take you to trial
complicated I love the atmosphere
it's so [ __ ] awesome alright enough
we go
so this is what other people most people
said it begins it's an Internet poll of
people aged 20 to 40 men only oh yeah I
didn't sign up I didn't put a I'm not
connected Internet
women only
it begins both both were very similar
that's really fun that's really
interesting I'll see where the other
career relationship question how they
relate what the [ __ ] am i doing running
there all right let's keep playing man
all right here we go more puzzling kind
of wish I selected normal but I think
later it's gonna be really hard and I
don't think you bros want to see me get
stuck a song
[Music]
try to remember it for later okay you
probably can't hold many but you should
hang on to one just in case okay I got
it [ __ ] I hate when they give us too
much information so annoying okay I can
go here and climb around okay I got an
item oh [ __ ] I used it by accident son
of a [ __ ]
cool yeah yeah your score is measured in
and [ __ ] my coins as you climb up each
new step more coins will be added to
your score okay that's literally what he
said as a condition for unlocking
additional game features
more bonus coins you were burned if you
want more coins okay I kind of got it
like it's like they tell you three times
so he's an [ __ ] and standing in the
way
although I could push him worth all
right all right edge [ __ ] lump I
don't know why it's tiny stuff in games
that's those satisfying what am i doing
I push these out oh they're so heavy
well that kind of makes sense if you
watch out for wobbling blocks
wobbling blocks I don't see any modeling
locks then pull oh that I knew that was
a trap okay I want the pillow though go
away
I want to push this we had the battle
bras we're almost there doggy dog two
creatures cannot stand on a block at the
same time sometimes people get in your
ways they try and climb to the top yeah
I already [ __ ] one up okay let me do
that [ __ ] why did I do that I don't
really need to do that edge chick point
[Music]
Oh guys thank you thanks
oh no I didn't notice that already come
on all right
so heavy law today did I [ __ ] up all
right
yeah I didn't know like what do I do now
[Music]
let's [ __ ] up I did [ __ ] up
good job hips you did it love it's over
I have to use a pillow oh no how can I
fail it easy all right it's okay don't
worry bad things happen in life
sometimes it goes up and sometimes it
goes down
let's get these points first push that
other way you know
there we go no where are you going they
accidentally jumped down before I'm such
an idiot
we lost our combo now - dad dammit brows
I'm really trying over here can't you
save a minute I don't think we'll get a
go one you escaped yay I mean um yeah I
tried all right I know I keep saying it
but it's really fun this game silver I
feel like I could it's the type of game
I would totally play again just to see
like the other exits points
I wish it would make this for your PC I
always hate plugging in my history this
is the pain in the ass
my life is so hard you don't understand
thank you maybe if I won some reason why
we were all brought here
I do have an idea can we just hug it out
you look so cute Elvis in the manga you
should think of what to do next
there's nothing more I can teach you
okay all right should we talk sit to
some sheets in sheep's cool i love sheep
school is my favorite school I go there
every day if I want to thank Mershon she
mercy
you've got money so creepy in the
background is here of course they made
that sheep fat
with coins if you are already carrying a
knife it will be replaced if you buy it
be careful Anthony - makes it more
difficult to earn the go but again the
white cube 5000 will be fine without it
for now it's good to keep on mine
[Music]
alright let's talk to these guys is he
gonna teach me that it means Elvis is
Elvis sheep sheep with regen hair they
call him I mean
this technique gives you more room
push a block off the legs with nothing
below and as long as the edges connect
the block will remain in place
i'ma regular block ologist that's a good
start another one you're teaching me
another one I asked blade I know all
about that what I'm sorry I'm so sorry
okay you can make like a ladder yeah I
know
I can't just rely on my natural
reporters
just techniques huh we guess the trick
is to learn as many of them as possible
okay you find any new moves come
straight to me
executive sheep out you know looked
again oh [ __ ] [ __ ] should we talk to
all of them I did say poor sheep
[Applause]
why is everything fallen let's just hug
it out
Allison we're helping other people too
I'm teaching him
[Music]
sometimes you got to go down to go up
okay
[Music]
that's awesome okay well we learned some
new moves should we talk to everyone I
mean I want to make sure I get all the
moves okay let's just talk to these two
really quick okay I'm a sheep all right
freedom up it says oh all right well we
only got loonatics left no I'll show you
[Music]
haha
that's not right okay so I'm still not
sure we should we look at this no we
can't I'm saying I'm sure we're gonna go
evil or good maybe I'll let you bros
decide live a comment what do you think
let's answer a question yeah a question
to ask the second question this is the
same feel the most call in a dark quiet
room or a bright and noisy room who
feels calm and in noisy planes what kind
of question is that which were like
quiet obviously that means I'm good
faith floor if I can get to the end I
don't have to die don't get your hopes
up you'll never be able to reach the
pinnacle anyway oh [ __ ] no night terrors
no
[ __ ] hell these outfits about the
burst
does that mean we survived night two or
are we stealing the night marry question
and answer all right let's see what
other people more people than the last
question it's very similar between boys
and girls this is kind of a weird
question I don't know it's like whatever
who cares all right I think we have one
more sage to get out of here to get out
of night - yeah final floor yep [ __ ]
love this style it's so cool all right
we get to use our new abilities now oh
[ __ ] me it's Marzia Jesus Christ oh my
god
do not die thank you take responsibility
oh my god
jesus [ __ ] christ I'm sorry Matty I'm
sorry
[Music]
this is [ __ ] stressing me the [ __ ]
out
can we make one of those two nadir
things going in can you stop - oh my god
does that change name still these are
just slower okay yeah got this [ __ ]
no problem wrists are you see on the map
oh my god it's coming close [ __ ] this I
don't know what this is but I want it I
can create a block oh my god I got a
hurry
oh [ __ ] that was close
no this alright this is the thing
what'd I do oh this is so stressful
I guess [ __ ] okay
[Music]
[ __ ] I [ __ ] up oh my [ __ ] god
stop doing that I don't know what I'm
doing okay no problem breasts alright I
got it
we did it bros and we got a sick [ __ ]
score too yeah that's how it's done it
would be awkward if it was locked
fantastic oh god oh god
oh [ __ ] Great Escape you survived a fire
best is that hallelujah song going it is
beautiful
what well today that we were doing
pretty good alright alright alright
I guess that guess see what you sees
would you so what'd you get
there's just save here so that means
we're gonna take a break here so much
fun playing this game brass if you
enjoyed please do leave it like it
really supports the show the series I
mean and I'll see you in the next one
Rose as always stay awesome
[Music]